κοντάμου κοντά μας κοντά μου προσωπικά για που ήταν στην κυβέρνηση τότε του νίκο αναστασία
δι ήταν οτότε υπουργός εξωτερικών και ενιν προτόναση της δημοκνατίας ο νοίκος οχριστοδουλίδης και εμπασκετσικός
πιο κοντά στας πόρτς και τα λπα ζητήσαμε να τον δούμε έτσιοβδερέρτε για να μας
καθοδηγήσει πω θα κάναμε και ματρία ενταξει όδια πρέε πάτε στον υπουργών οικονομικώ εγώ εννοήται
θα στηρίξω όλον αυτό το το εγχείρημα και θα σας βοηθήσει όταν έρθει ορα αλλά
πρέπει να πάθε στον υπουργών οικονομικών τότε ήταν ο κονσταντίνος ο πετρίδης με το προφίλ
του τσάρου της οικονομία του απρόσεη τουπρονσταντίνως οπετρίδης αλλά μας λέει όταν πάτε εκεί πρέπει
να πάτε μια ντεκμηρίωση για να έχετε προστά σα στα δεδομένα τους αριθμους να ανοίξουμε
να παράθεση κι να αποω ότη υπαρέα μεγάλωσε και κείναμεντρει σήπουν εγώ άθως αντονίο αλλά
και ο μάρκο κληρίδη ο οποίος μάρκι ίναι πιο κατεχνοκράτης αλλά αμπασκετσικώς εκατό της έκανω
και καταλήξαμ να κάουμε μια μελέ την από την ιγουάη μετά πρέπει να πει τώρα
αντεπούμε των υπουργών ικονομικών βάλαμε και τοραντεύού πηγανο έτσι ψαρωμένη στων κονσταντίνων των πετρίδην τότε
και μας ψάρωσε και πολύ περισσότερο όταν μπήγαμε στο στο γραφείων του καθόταν έτσι στο
βάθο τογραφείων του μας έβαλε δεξιά στων καραή εφαντάσω τώρα πως κάνετε συνεδρίεσων που τη
που εβάλιέεραδεκατεμετεραάδια θα μας εγκρίνεια ναι μας πίες δεγκαιο χρόνος για να υποβάλουμε και τα
λιπά πουσυστηνοση στην νόμεξέρω ξεκινούμε και του λέμε τη διαδικασία και σε κάποια φάση του
κοινήσαμε έτσι την περιέργεια ήρθε ίναι κατσι μαζί μας και από δέκα τεκαντε λεπτά που
ήταν προγραμματισμένη η συνάντηση μας πήρε ν αρκετήν ώρα και μας είαι